es hätte heute live herzlich willkommen
vor dem bundeskanzler liegt eine woche
die es in sich hat es gleich drei
internationale gipfeltreffen warten auf
ihn nacheinander versammeln sich eu g7
und nato das alles innerhalb der
nächsten tage und dabei wird vor allem
natürlich der krieg in der ukraine im
vordergrund stehen aus diesem anlass
gibt der kanzler in wenigen minuten eine
regierungserklärung ab im anschluss
daran wird dann eine antwort des
oppositionsführers friedrich merz
erwartet die wir dann auch beide live
zeigen wollen wir sprechen dann in
dieser sendung später noch mit dem nato
general egon ramms mit unserer
korrespondentin in der ukraine mit
katrin eigendorf und zu beginn mit
unseren kollegen im hauptstadtstudio mit
daniel kurzen hallo daniel
vor dem kanzler wir haben es gesagt
liegt eine ereignisreiche woche mit dem
auftakt eu gipfel was wird denn von
seiner regierungserklärung in wenigen
minuten erwartet die wird also ein
vorausblick seien auf eben diese drei
gipfeltreffen die ja du hast gesagt das
thema ukraine in sämtlichen facetten
beleuchtet wird
mit unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten
natürlich und innenpolitisch wird es
natürlich nach wie vor vor allem um die
frage gehen inwieweit deutschland die
ukraine unterstützt unter anderem auch
mit waffen unterstützt das ist ja die
frage die seit brauchen wir nicht
monaten die dort die deutsche
öffentlichkeit beschäftigt wie wohl
keine andere gestern gab es daher eine
nachrichtliche entwicklung gehen wir
sicher später noch mal drauf ein aber
wie gesagt insgesamt soll es über diesen
innenpolitischen blick hinaus ein
vorausblick seien auf eben diese drei
gipfeltreffen bei denen ja auch globale
fragen behandelt werden insbesondere die
kritische frage
zur welt ernährungssituation die sich ja
immer mehr verschärft aber darüber
hinaus soll es vor allem bei g7
natürlich auch
umwelt wirtschaftliche fragen der
zusammenarbeit gehen auch hier haben
sich ja tektonische verschiebungen
angedeutet zuletzt ebenso wie bei
sicherheitsfragen die dann natürlich vor
allem beim gipfel in madrid ab dienstag
nächster woche auf dem programm stehen
werden wir sprechen gleich weiter daniel
wir gucken natürlich auch immer mit
einem auge auf den bundestag wenn es
losgeht sind wir natürlich dann live
dabei bei der regierungserklärung fragen
und kommentare wie immer natürlich gerne
an uns über e-mail oder über social
media
wir wollen unseren zuschauern und
zuschauerinnen vorher noch mal kurz
zeigen bevor wir weiter sprechen welche
seltener gipfel marathon gibt es
wirklich so nicht alle tage in den
nächsten tagen bevorsteht
am donnerstag und freitag beraten die
staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union in brüssel
im mittelpunkt stehen die beitritts
kandidaturen der ukraine und moldau die
eu kommission hat bereits empfohlen
beide länder offiziell zur kandidatin
für den eu-beitritt zu ernennen im
bayrischen elmau kommen von sonntag an
die staats und regierungschefs der
sieben führenden industrienationen
zusammen auf dem g7 gipfel wird es neben
dem ukraine krieg auch um den
klimawandel und den globalen kampf gegen
den hunger gehen
auch beim nato gipfel in madrid dreht
sich kommende woche alles um den krieg
in der ukraine die bündnispartner wollen
eine erhebliche verstärkung der
abschreckungs und verteidigungs
kapazitäten beschließen thema dürfte
auch die geplante aufnahme von finnland
und schweden seien die derzeit von der
türkei blockiert wird
also da gibt es viel zu besprechen die
bundesregierung daniel hat gestern
erstmals konkret veröffentlicht was
bisher an material in die ukraine
geliefert wurde beziehungsweise was noch
geliefert werden soll wie es das zu
interpretieren ist das eine
vorwärtsverteidigung des bundeskanzlers
der bundesregierung wird ihm das heute
helfen im umgang mit der opposition
es geht zumindest sehr viele davon aus
dass das so eine art
vorwärtsverteidigung sein sollte das war
schon im vorfeld bekannt geworden dass
es einen antrag geben wird aus der
opposition spricht von cdu csu die einen
ganzen forderungskatalog aufgestellt
haben der sich um die frage
dreht inwiefern deutschland jetzt noch
stärker waffen liefern soll und daher
ist es zum beispiel ganz konkret
wörtlich als kernforderung dass endlich
die deutschen waffenlieferungen in
quantität und qualität
unverzüglich und spürbar intensiviert
werden müssen und das ist nur eine der
forderungen wie gesagt nun gab es jetzt
gestern die veröffentlichung dieser
liste was ja schon ein ziemlicher
quantensprung in der kommunikation
gewesen ist offiziell hat man das damit
begründet dass man sich der
kommunikationsstrategie der westlichen
partner
angleichen anpassen wolle was natürlich
die frage aufwirft warum man es dann
vorher genau umgekehrt gemacht hat
damals herrschte ja geheimhaltung als
oberstes prinzip selbst abgeordnete
konnten diese listen nur einsehen ohne
sich zum beispiel kopien machen zu
können oder fotografien das heißt er
wurde größter wert auf geheimhaltung
gelegt das hat man nun sozusagen dieses
prinzip über bord geworfen ist nun in
die transparenz hinein gegangen diese
liste sogar im eben im internet
veröffentlicht allerdings transparenz
auch in gewisser weise eingeschränkt
denn diese liste ist ja zweigeteilt teil
1 betrifft die waffen die schon
geliefert worden sind nicht nur waffen
sondern auch
ausrüstung für die
soldatinnen und soldaten und teil 2 das
beinhaltet eben dann vor allen dingen
auch die schweren waffen geliefert
werden sollen
ist nach wie vor unklar wann gekommen
und im zusammenhang damit ist sicher
auch zu sehen die meldung gestern dass
die sieben panzerhaubitzen angekommen
seien in der ukraine was von der ukraine
bestätigt wurden und somit der
bundeskanzler eben auch sagen kann dass
nun schwere waffen geliefert worden sind
wenngleich eben eine vielzahl von dem
schweren gerät das versprochen wurde
nach wie vor nicht geliefert ist und
nach wie vor unklar ist wann und ob es
geliefert wird ich kann an der stelle
vielleicht gerade unseren userinnen und
user noch mal zeigen dass wir diese
liste von der lohe auch gerade schon
gesprochen heißt dass wir die auch auf
unserer seite zu heute.de auch natürlich
zur verfügung gestellt hbz weh euch da
draußen gerne zugänglich machen wollen
da ist also noch mal aufgeführt wir
werden das später auch nochmal mit dem
general ramms darüber sprechen welche
waffensysteme in vorbereitung sind
beziehungsweise welche schon geliefert
worden sind also das vielleicht auch
noch mal für euch zum verfolgen der
sendung ganz interessant so daniel wir
haben vorhin schon gehört im parlament
die
bundesverteidigungsministerium oder
andersrum ich ziehe gerade eine
zuschauerfrage noch ein weil das
vielleicht jetzt in dem zusammenhang
auch noch mal ganz interessant ist dance
bevor fragt uns wäre es nicht klüger
keine informationen über irgendwelche
waffenlieferungen zu veröffentlichen
also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere war
das so ein bisschen das argument auch
der regierung bis gestern das ist
vielleicht auch unter wie auch immer
militärischen geheimdienstlichen was
auch immer gesichtspunkten nützlich sein
könnte nicht zu veröffentlichen aber
lässt sich vielleicht auf dauer auch
nicht durchhalten
ja es hat sich ja bisher durchhalten
lassen insofern hätte man es natürlich
schon so weitermachen können die frage
ist allerdings ob diese begründung
tatsächlich in sich somit nicht
konsistent ist denn jetzt nachträglich
zu sagen was man geliefert hat darin
besteht ja im grunde auch keine gefahr
die die immer betont wurde dass man
natürlich nicht mitteilt wann man
welches gerät über welche route konkret
an liefert das ist natürlich völlig klar
und das glaube ich hatte aber auch von
den kritikern niemand verlangt aber eine
gewisse transparenz darüber was denn
konkret geliefert wird die haben andere
länder ja schon geliefert manche sogar
durchaus mit einigem stolz auch darauf
verwiesen dass die bundesregierung
anders gemacht manche vermuten dahinter
eher die strategie dass man eben die
direkte konfrontation mit moskau nicht
betonen möchte durch diese lieferung da
eher zurückhaltender agiert was am ende
der die konkrete die konkrete intention
des bundeskanzlers hier hinter ist dass
darüber kann man nur spekulieren das
muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
was er dafür am wahrscheinlichsten
hätten ja die
bundesverteidigungsministerium wollte
ich gerade schon darauf zu sprechen
kommen frau lambrecht musste sich heute
im parlament bereits rede und antwort
musste rede und antwort stehen und wurde
von der opposition auch relativ hart
befragt wir hören mal rein was die
ministerin gesagt hat da muss ich sagen
da sind ja ziemlich an die grenzen an
den an der ganze angelangt dessen was
noch für handball verantwortbar ist wenn
ich als deutsche verteidigungsministerin
eben die landes- und bündnisverteidigung
gewährleisten möchte
also das war ein o-ton von ihrer ging es
um die panzerhaubitzen auch um mass das
wird alles eine länder abgabe sein hat
sie gesagt und das erfolgt über die
bundeswehr und wir haben es gerade
gehört man wäre damit an den grenzen
dessen was verantwortbar sei wie ist das
einzuschätzen wird das von der
opposition geteilt wie würdest du die
situation im bundestag zu schreiben ja
es gibt schon einigkeit darüber dass die
bundeswehr da natürlich nicht
endlos liefern kann liegt an dem er
durchaus beklagenswerten zustand der
bundeswehr in die sie gebracht worden
ist über viele jahre beziehungsweise
jahrzehnte umso interessanter ist
natürlich die unterscheidung die die
ministerin ihr trifft und zwar wenn es
darum geht zu unterscheiden zwischen dem
was aus analysen zum ende kommen wir
können das vielleicht gleich nochmal
aufgreifen aber gern bundeskanzler
schreitet antreten obwohl danke für den
moment wir hören herrn scholz
[Applaus]
anfang des monats haben wir das
fundament einer neuen
sicherheitsarchitektur für unser land
gelegt mit überwältigender mehrheit hat
dieses haus ja gesagt zum sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr
allen die das mit ihrer zustimmung
möglich gemacht hat hier im bundestag
und auch im bundesrat sage ich heute vom
herzen danke
sicherheit ist das fundamentalste
versprechen dass ein staat seinen
bürgern und bürgern schuldet und dieses
versprechen haben wir erneuert im
angesicht des russischen angriffskrieges
im angesicht der zeitenwende meine damen
und herren wir
werden die bundeswehr so ausstatten dass
sie unser land und unser bündnispartner
gegen alle angriffe wirksam verteidigen
kann das ist der maßstab für die neue
bundeswehr
damit bekommen wir auch für unsere
soldaten sind daten endlich die
unterstützung die sie verdienen bei
ihrem wichtigen dienst für unser land
und dafür sage ich ebenfalls hoffentlich
im namen von uns allen hier danke
die neuausrichtung unserer
sicherheitspolitik ist bei unseren
freunden in europa und in der welt auf
anerkennung gestoßen unsere botschaft
wird verstanden in der größten
sicherheits krise europas seit
jahrzehnten übernimmt deutschland das
wirtschaftsstärkste und
bevölkerungsreichster gleiches bei der
union ganz besondere verantwortung und
zwar nicht nur für seine eigene
sicherheit sondern eben auch für die
sicherheit seiner agierten bei meinem
besuch vor zwei wochen im baltikum habe
ich klar gestellt ein angriff auf euch
wäre ein angriff auf uns alle
und wir belassen es nicht bei worten
unmittelbar nach kriegsbeginn haben wir
zusätzliche soldaten soldaten und
militärischen fähigkeiten zb zur
luftabwehr ins östliche bundesgebiet
verlegt
und mit dem litauischen präsidentin
aussehe habe ich vereinbart dass wir die
deutsche präsenz dort dauerhaft
verstärken und litauen eine robuste
bundeswehr brigade feste zuordnung
wir werden außerdem unsere präsenz mit
luft und marine streitkräften im
ostseeraum aushalten und wir sind dabei
soldaten soldaten in die slowakei zu
entsenden und die slowakei bei der
sicherung ihres luftraums zu
unterstützen weil das untermauert was
ich schon am 27
februar im bundestag gesagt habe wir
werden jeden quadratmeter des
bündnisgebietes verteidigen
aus unserer eigenen geschichte wissen
wir deutschen doch was wir diese zusage
zu verdanken haben und deshalb können
unsere nato partner im osten europas
sich heute auf deutschland verlassen
mit dieser zusage geben wir den nato
gipfel kommende woche
und weil sich dort auch andere
verbündete mit ganz konkreten beiträgen
zu unserer gemeinsamen sicherheits-
verantwortung bekennen werden bin ich
fest überzeugt vom nato gipfel wird ein
signal des zusammenhalts der
entschlossenheit ausgehen mit einem
neuen strategischen konzept werden wir
die nato auf die herausforderung für die
zukunft einstellen das künftige
verhältnis zu russland spielt dabei eine
wichtige rolle um es klar zu sagen eine
partnerschaft mit russland wie sie noch
das strategische konzept von 2010 als
ziel ausgegeben hat ist mit putins
aggressiven imperialistischen russland
auf absehbare zeit unvorstellbar
doch wir sollten daraus keine falschen
schlüsse ziehen es wäre unklug
unsererseits die nato russland grund
akte aufzukündigen
das würde nur präsident putin und seiner
propaganda in die hände spielen die nato
russland grund hatte bekräftigt genau
die prinzipien gegen die putin verstoßen
hat und verstößt den verzicht auf gewalt
die achtung von grenzen die souveränität
unabhängiger staaten daran sollten wir
putin immer wieder erinnern wir werden
jedenfalls uns mehr denn je für den
erhalt der internationalen ordnung stark
machen die aufrecht statt auf gewalt
basiert gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
und at t
zu diesen addiert da bin ich
zuversichtlich werden bald auch schweden
und finnland gehören für uns alle denke
ich ist klar schweden und finnland sind
als neue verbündete ein
sicherheitsgewinn für alle nato
mitglieder und für ganz europa
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich
in den nächsten tagen am treffen der eu
mit den westbalkanstaaten am
europäischen rat am g 7 gipfel beim
treffen der nato staats und
regierungschefs teilnehmen dann werden
mich die eindrücke meines besuchs in der
ukraine begleiten
da sind vor allem die änderung an das
kriegszerstörte
ich werde sie nicht vergessen die
frischen gräbern die zerbombten
wohnblocks die zerstörten brücken die
von schüssen durchsiebte autos sie
sprechen eine eindeutige sprache
russland führt einen erbarmungslosen
krieg gegen das ukrainische volk gegen
unschuldige frauen männer und kinder
haben das ist ein barbarisches
verbrechen und die ukraine hat jedes
recht sich dagegen zur wehr zu setzen
und es ist unsere pflicht als
europäische nachbarn als verteidiger von
recht und freiheit als freunde und
partner der ukraine sie dabei
bestmöglich zu unterstützen
europa steht geschlossen an der seite
des ukrainischen volkes das ist die
botschaft die manuell marco mario draghi
klaus johannis und ich mit nach kiel
gebracht haben und ich habe präsident
zellen ski versichert wir werden die
ukraine auch weiter massiv unterstützt
und finanziell wirtschaftlich humanitär
politisch und nicht zuletzt mit der
lieferung von waffen- und zwar so lange
wie die ukraine unsere unterstützung
braucht
die ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten
soldaten an den fleck panzern gebhard
läuft an den zugesagten mehrfach
raketenwerfern beginnt sie in den
kommenden tagen der vertrag über das
luftabwehrsystem iris t dass eine ganze
großstadt vor feindlichen luftangriff
geschützt wurde vor wenigen tagen
zwischen der ukraine und der industrie
unterzeichnet
ein erster ringtausch in tschechien
steht gespräche mit weiteren
tauschpartnern führen wir mit hochdruck
und ich kann mitteilen was sich gestern
schon rumgesprochen hat die
panzerhaubitzen an dem wir ukrainische
soldatinnen soldaten im vergangenen
wochen intensiv trainiert haben sind
inzwischen vor ort in der ukraine
die ukraine bekommt die waffen die sie
in der jetzigen phase des krieges
besonders braucht und genau über diese
liefern und diese waffen habe ich mit
dem ukrainischen präsidenten gesprochen
wir liefern sie heute und in zukunft
und damit wir alle künftig auf basis von
fakten wird diese entscheidung
diskutieren hat die bundesregierung
entschieden eine übersicht über alle
schon erfolgten und alle kommenden
waffenlieferung zu veröffentlichen
analog zur praxis viele verbündete
meine damen und herren steht der pin
oder butter sind orte des grauens
aber ihre pin und die anderen befreiten
orte machen wir auch etwas hoffnung
hoffnung dass es gelingen kann die
russischen angreifer mit vereinten
kräften zurückzudrängen und das bleibt
unser ziel
deshalb werden wir mit präsident
selensky auch über weitere unterstützung
für die ukraine beraten immer ohne dass
die nato dadurch selbst zur kriegspartei
wird und noch etwas haben wir präsident
seelands hier bei unserem besuch in kiew
versichert die ukraine
und nur die ukraine entscheidet in
möglichen verhandlungen mit russland was
für sie richtig ist nichts über die
ukraine ohne die ukraine unsere gebiete
die wahrheit das doch wir sind von
verhandlungen zwischen der ukraine und
russland weit weit entfernt bei putin
noch immer an die möglichkeit eines
diktat friedens glaubt
umso entscheidender ist es dass wir
standhaft kurs halten mit unseren
sanktionen mit den international
abgestimmten waffenlieferung und mit
unserer finanziellen unterstützung für
die ukraine so lange bis putin seine
kolossale fehleinschätzung endlich
erkennt
bei alldem meine damen und herren
brauchen wir einen langen atem und auch
der wiederaufbau der ukraine wird eine
generationenaufgabe
auch das wird einem in den zerschossenen
häuserruinen von pin sehr deutlich das
ausmaß der zerstörung ist enorm manches
dort erinnert nicht nur mich an die
bilder der zerstörten deutschen steht
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
und wie damals das kriegszerstörte
europa braucht heute auch die ukraine
einen marshall plan für einen
wiederaufbau
die eu hat in den letzten hundert tagen
mittel in milliarden höhe zur
unterstützung der ukraine mobilisiert
deutschland ist immer vorne mit dabei
aber wir werden viele weitere milliarden
euro und dollar für den wiederaufbau
brauchen und das über jahre hinweg
es geht nur mit vereinten kräften
gemeinsam mit den internationalen
finanzorganisationen mit anderen großen
geberländern mit anderen internationalen
organisationen
ich habe präsident selensky zum g 7
gipfel nach elba eingeladen um auch
darüber zu reden
neben den finanzmitteln ist eines
besonders entscheidend wir müssen uns
darüber verständigen auch mit den rat
von experten experten und
wissenschaftlern wie ein solcher
marshallplan für die ukraine aus sehen
kann wie wir international koordinieren
wie wir künftig gemeinsam entscheiden
welche investitionen die ukraine am
schnellsten voran bringen auf ihrem
europäischen weg
und gemeinsam mit der
kommissionspräsidentin werde ich deshalb
auch
beim europäischen rat oder anderer
stelle dafür werben eine hochrangige
internationale
expertenkonferenz einzuberufen und zwar
im rahmen unserer g7 präsidentschaft eng
abgestimmt mit internet
der europäische weg der ukraine war das
zentrale thema meines besuchs in kiew
und emanuel makler für hannes mal betrag
und ich haben unisono klargestellt die
ukraine gehört zur europäischen familie
deshalb werbe ich werde ich mich auch
beim europäischen rat morgen und
übermorgen mit allem nachdruck dafür
einsetzen dass die gesamte eu
geschlossen ja sagt
27 mal ja zum kandidatenstatus
deutschland ist für eine positive
entscheidung übrigens auch für die
republik moldau und
in diesen tagen gab und gibt es wohl
keinen passenden ort um das
klarzustellen dass kiew seite an seite
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten seite
an seite auch mit freunden und partnern
aus alten und neuen eu mitgliedsstaaten
aus dem norden süden osten westen
inzwischen hat die kommission unsere
haltung ausdrücklich unterstützt und
zugleich pc klare reformschritte pendant
richtschnur zielmarke sind die
kopenhagen der kriterien von besonderer
bedeutung sind dabei fragen der
rechtsstaatlichkeit
die weitere reform des gerichtswesens
der kampf gegen korruption und der
schutz von minderheiten
auch die ukraine ukraine wissen der weg
in die eu ist voraussetzung reich aber
sie wollen den weg jetzt gehen weil sie
sich davon weniger korruption weniger
einfluss von oligarchen mehr
rechtsstaatlichkeit mehr transparenz
mehr demokratie und eine stärkere
wirtschaft versprechen
das ist die hoffnung die auch wir mit
dem weg der ukraine richtung eu
verbinden und dabei werden wir die
ukraine unterstützen
das gilt übrigens auch für georgien
dessen europäische perspektive
weiterförderung wollen zugleich wissen
wir auch die eu muss sich auf den
beitritt neuer mitglieder vorbereiten
das heißt dass wir unsere internen
strukturen und verfahren reformieren
müssen
deshalb werbe ich intensiv dafür künftig
mehr entscheidungen mit qualifizierter
mehrheit zu treffen etwa in der
außenpolitik
wir müssen die europäische union
aufnahmefähig machen das erfordert
institutionelle reform und wir sollten
diese reform nutzen um demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit auch in der
europäischen union zu stärken
die entscheidung zu den kandidaten
status der ukraine und moldau es ist
eine antwort europas auf die zeitenwende
dieselbe klare antwort verdienen auch
die länder des westlichen balkans
deshalb war es mir wichtig die region
vor meiner reise in die ukraine zu
besuchen
fast 20 jahre ist es her dass die eu
diesen ländern den beitritt in aussicht
gestellt hat in thessaloniki
ich war vor wenigen tagen dort
und alle haben mich daran erinnert als
das damals beschlossen wurde in
thessaloniki am gleichen ort
da haben alle gedacht so in fünf bis
acht jahren sind die alle mitglied
und das hat sich bis heute
nicht bewahrheitet
deshalb
muss in diesen neuen zeiten klar sein
jetzt gilt es wir wollen und wir
brauchen den westlichen balkan in der
europäischen union
das war meine botschaft bei meiner reise
in die region und das wird auch die
botschaft sein die vom morgigen treffen
mit den sechs westbalkan staaten
ausgehen muss und sage ich ganz
ausdrücklich
es findet nun hoffentlich statt wir
haben heute auch verfolgt dass das nicht
so sicher machen und darüber darf man
sich ehrlicherweise braucht nicht
wundern denn wenn man hoffnung erweckt
wenn man nationen wenn man länder auf
den weg bringt und sie davon überzeugt
dass es sich lohnt auf
den weg in die eu sich zu machen und es
werden anstrengungen unternommen es
werde politische konflikte im eigenen
land riskiert man ein land hat seinen
namen geändert nord mazedonien um den
streit mit griechenland beizutreten
legen und dann hilft das alles nichts
und die dinge kommen nicht voran dann
ist es völlig richtig dass das stöhr
gefühl dass die politisch
verantwortlichen dieser länder und ihre
bürgerinnen bürger haben auch
ausgedrückt wird deshalb wird das
bestimmt kein einfacher gipfel mit
diesen staaten aber es ist richtig dass
wir uns da so positionieren dass sie
wissen deutschland ist auf ihrer seite
die trophy sehr dass nun alle über ihren
schatten springen und ihre verantwortung
für das große ganze sehen die eu muss
endlich grünes licht geben für
beitrittsverhandlungen mit albanien und
mazedonien
das will ich ja auch sagen meine
gespräche mit dem bulgarischen
ministerpräsidenten haben mir gezeigt
dass er sehr konstruktiv in die
gespräche mit körper herangeht und wir
wissen auch
heute finden darüber heftige debatten in
dem land statt denn das ist immer wieder
das was das miteinander in europa so
schwierig macht dass dinge die irgendwie
ein fundament in lange zurückliegenden
ereignissen der geschichte haben
plötzlich aktuell genutzt werden um
alles mögliche durcheinander zu bringen
was eine friedliche zukunft von uns
ermöglicht und deshalb hoffe ich dass
bulgarien ein weg wählt ein weg der es
möglich macht dass es seine eigene kraft
entfalten kann im europäischen union
aber mit seinen ängsten nachbarn im
westlichen balkan vereint
und unterstütze deshalb die bemühungen
der französischen ratspräsidentschaft
ein kompromiss zu vermitteln und eben
ich hoffe dass alle ihre streitigkeiten
beilegen ein stabiler wohlhabender
europäischer westbalkan liegt
schließlich in unser aller interesse
liebe kolleginnen kollegen noch etwas
hat bei unserem besuch in kiew eine
wichtige rolle gespielt
wir haben über die globalen folgen des
kriegs gesprochen über steigende
energiepreise und knappe rohstoffe
abgestimmt mit unseren europäischen und
internationalen partnern tun wir alles
dafür um vorsorge für den winter zu
treffen das gilt besonders für die
energieversorgung und wir arbeiten auch
an lösungen für die ausfuhr von
ukrainischen nahrungsmitteln
erst gestern habe ich mit dem
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
noch einmal darüber diskutiert wie wir
die verhandlungen jetzt zu einem guten
ergebnis führen können es kann sich
dabei bleiben dass millionen ukraine
getreide in speichern feststeckt obwohl
sie weltweit dringend gebraucht werden
die vereinten nationen waren schon vor
der größten hungersnot seit jahrzehnten
dabei kämpfen viele länder des globalen
südens noch mit den folgen der pandemie
wenn es uns nicht gelingt diesen ländern
solidarisch beizustehen dann werden
möchte wie russland und china das
ausnutzen
deshalb ist es von ganz entscheidender
bedeutung
von den gipfeltreffen der kommenden tage
muss nicht nur die botschaft ausgehen
dass die europäische union die nato und
die g7 so beschlossen zusammen stehen
wie nie
sondern auch dass die demokratien der
welt zusammenstehen im kampf gegen
putins imperialismus
aber eben genauso im kampf gegen hunger
und armut gegen gesundheits krisen und
den klimawandel
mit dem tunesien und indien habe ich
daher die aktuelle und künftige g20
präsidentschaft zum gipfel eingeladen
auch weniger als präsidentschaft der
afrikanischen union in argentinien als
vorsitz der gemeinschaft
lateinamerikanischer und karibischer
staaten und südafrika wird mit am tisch
sitzen
als präsidentschaft der g 7 haben wir
vorarbeit geleistet zusammen mit der
weltbank haben wir bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit ins leben gerufen
mit einem pakt zur bekämpfung künftiger
pandemien wollen wir die früherkennung
von möglichen ausdrücken und unsere
reaktionsfähigkeit stärke und wir werden
über die rolle von demokratien sprechen
bei der verteidigung offener residente
gesellschaften und der durchsetzung von
menschenrechten und nicht zuletzt
brauchen wir dringend fortschritte beim
klima und umweltschutz
ich habe daher einen offenen
kooperativen klima club vorgeschlagen
und ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir
ihnen elf immer weiter aufs gleis setzen
das ziel ist ein internationaler markt
mit vergleichbaren standards ein markt
der länder für klimafreundliches
wirtschaften belohnt und werk griff und
sie vor wettbewerbsnachteilen
klimaschutz wird damit zum wettlauf um
wettbewerbsvorteile
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die zeitenwende war nie nur eine
zustandsbeschreibung
aus ihr ergibt sich ein handlungsauftrag
an unser land in europa an die
internationale gemeinschaft
als land haben wir die weichen neu
gestellt
wir investieren massiv in unsere
sicherheit wir lösen das versprechen
deutscher sicherheitsverantwortung für
europa ein wir werden energie unabhängig
von russland und wir werden klimaneutral
jetzt erst recht
auf den internationalen gipfeltreffen
der kommenden tage werden wir ähnlich
tief greifende veränderungen anstoßen
die europäische union muss sich zur
europäischen zukunft ihrer nachbarschaft
bekennen und zu den notwendigen internen
reformen die nato wird geschlossen wie
nie die sicherheitspolitischen antworten
auf die herausforderungen zeit geben und
die g7 wird klare zeichen setzen für
mehr klimaschutz mehr internationale
zusammenarbeit und mehr globale
solidarität
deutschland spielt bei all dem eine
zentrale rolle an unser land richten
sich große erwartungen wir stellen uns
dieser verantwortung
und das wird die aufgabe der nächsten
tage seien schönen dank
ich eröffne hiermit die aussprache und
als erster hat das wort friedrich merz
für die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren wir
erleben zurzeit in der tat die tiefste
zäsur der europäischen geschichte nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg
das ergebnis der jetzt in sehr dichter
abfolge
stattfindenden gipfeltreffen der
europäischen union der g7 und der nato
werden auf lange zeit die politische
ordnung auf unserem kontinent und damit
das leben der menschen in ganz europa
und darüber hinaus bestimmen herr
bundeskanzler wir haben aus überzeugung
mitgestimmt bei der neuausrichtung der
deutschen sicherheitspolitik und bei der
neuen finanzierung der bundeswehr das
ist ein wesentlicher bestandteil einer
neuen deutschen und damit auch einen
neuen europäischen sicherheitspolitik
wir begrüßen ausdrücklich dass sie in
der letzten woche sagen nun endlich in
kiew gewesen sind und dass sie dort mit
dem französischen staatspräsidenten dem
rumänischen präsidenten besonders
wichtig und
dem französischen staatspräsidenten zu
besuch waren das war ein wichtiges
zeichen der europäischen solidarität mit
diesem unverändert geschundenen land und
seinen menschen
dieser besucher war meine damen und
herren ändert nichts daran der russische
vernichtungskrieg in der ukraine trägt
von tag zu tag mehr so sagt es das
wahrenberg center for human rights die
zentralen merkmale eines intendierten
völkers wir alle sie die mitglieder der
bundesregierung wir die mitglieder des
deutschen bundestages haben in diesen
tagen den brief einer großen zahl von
anerkannten historiker
völkerrechtlern und weiteren personen
des öffentlichen lebens erhalten die uns
alle zusammen eindringlich auffordern
auch unsere schutzverantwortung für die
ukraine nachzukommen und die immer
größer werdende gefahr eines
völkermordes abzuwenden wir stehen zu
dieser verantwortung auch als cdu csu
politik erzählt
aber das ganze großen ausdrücklich dass
nun auch endlich die lieferung der
waffen in gang kommt die wir hier
gemeinsam am 28 april im deutschen
bundestag mit sehr großer mehrheit
beschlossen haben und die sie schon seit
wochen ankündigen es hatte offenbar in
ihrer regierung einen meinungswechsel
gegeben im hinblick auf die
veröffentlichung und auch auf die
lieferung wir begrüßen das ausdrücklich
wir hätten es uns früher vorstellen
können
die vereinigung angesichts der tatsache
wichtig dass russland nun offenbar dabei
ist auch die spannungen zu einem
weiteren nachbarland zu verschaffen
nämlich gegenüber litauen
bundeskanzler sie haben das mit einem
halbsatz hier auch angesprochen fühlt es
etwas deutlicher sagen dies zeigt dass
wir in unserer einschätzung richtig
liegen dass putin in der ukraine
gestoppt werden muss wenn das nicht
gelingt
nun will ich allerdings unserer
überraschung schon ein wenig ausdruck
verleihen dass nun ausgerechnet in einer
solchen lage
der außenpolitische berater des
bundeskanzlers ihr wichtigster
mitarbeiter in der außenpolitik im
bundeskanzleramt ist für richtig und
angezeigt hält öffentlich darüber zu
räsonieren wie denn unser verhältnis zu
russland sein könnte wörtlich mit 20 ma
dann kann man viele zeitungsseiten
füllen aber artikel darüber wie wird
unser verhältnis zu russland sein gibt
es jetzt irgendwie weniger ende des
zitats
bundeskanzler solche äußerungen sind
genau die äußerungen aus ihrer
bundesregierung die im inland und noch
mehr im europäischen ausland und
außerhalb der europäischen union
berechtigte zweifel daran
auslösen ob sie es wirklich erst mal mit
dem was sie auch heute hier an dieser
stelle aus wieder gedacht
sie verlieren mit diesen zweifeln aus
ihren eigenen reihen das wichtigste
kapital das sie gerade jetzt in dieser
internationalen krise brauchen nämlich
vertrauen und verlässlichkeit in den
deutschen bundeskanzler machen meine
damen und herren immerhin sie haben auch
schon mal witziger zwischenrufe gemacht
immerhin
der beschluss meine damen und herren der
beschluss der staats- und
regierungschefs
ich vermisse übrigens in ihren reihen
den parteivorsitzenden der spd wo ist er
eigentlich der macht hierzu vorschläge
zur außen- und sicherheitspolitik und
dann sieht man mal in ihren reihen die
hälfte der spd-bundestagsfraktion fehlt
was ist eigentlich los herr
bundeskanzler in ihrer eigenen koalition
das noch nicht
die opposition heute da sind in ihren
ausführungen hierzu gehört haben wir
sind da und hören zu also immerhin der
beschluss der staats und regierungschefs
meine damen und herren über den stand
kandidatenstatus der ukraine ist wichtig
er ist ein wichtiges politisches signal
des europäischen zusammenhalt aber wir
alle wissen der beschluss allein die
ukraine jetzt in den kandidatenstatus zu
setzen hilft diesem land noch nicht und
sie ist die ukraine von einer
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
damit wir wissen es noch viele jahre
entfernt deswegen stellt sich die
berechtigte frage was geschieht in der
eu und mit der ukraine eigentlich in der
zeit bis dahin
sie haben sich ein bundeskanzler bei
anderer gelegenheit offen gezeigt zu
haben sie es gesagt für den vorschlag
des französischen präsidenten einer
europäischen politischen gemeinschaft
nun sind diese vorschläge zwischen der
vollmitgliedschaft und der
nichtmitgliedschaft eine art zwischen
status zu schaffen auch institutionell
abzusichern in der europäischen union
nicht neu aus unseren reihen hier aus
dem deutschen bundestag aus der
bundestagsfraktion der cdu/csu sind seit
1994 vorschläge gemacht worden für eine
abgestufte integration innerhalb der
europäischen union aber was folgt denn
nun daraus in der französische
staatspräsident eine solche frage stellt
was ist die antwort auf der
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland ich finde europa könnte in
der tat und ich meine sogar europa muss
bis zur vollmitgliedschaft der
europäischen der ukraine in der
europäischen union einen weg finden um
die beitrittskandidaten und eben nicht
nur die ukraine sondern auch moldau
möglicherweise auch georgien schritt für
schritt an diese europäische union
heranzuführen
der bus der der französische präsident
meine damen und herren noch weitere
vorschläge gemacht für die reform der
europäischen union hat unter anderem
vorgeschlagen eine reform des
maastricht-vertrages und es ist
aufschlussreich dass sie in ihrer
regierungserklärung heute morgen kein
wort darüber verlor nun haben dass sie
auch die präsidentin der europäischen
zentralbank an diesem gipfel der
europäischen union teilnimmt und dort
einen ausblick über die finanz- und
wirtschaftspolitische lage geben wird
meine damen und herren ich will es von
unserer seite aus hier jedenfalls
festhalten für uns gibt es keinen
zweifel daran dass wir am
maastricht-vertrag und dass wir am
stabilitäts und wachstumspakt der
europäischen union ohne wenn und aber
festhalten wird
diese liebe zu geben denn meine damen
und herren wenig überlegungen aus der
europäischen zentralbank höre dass man
jetzt der fragmentierung der eurozone
begegnen will dann sind dies erste
hinweise darauf dass offensichtlich die
europäische zentralbank vor hat
außerhalb ihres mandats weitere
stützungsmaßnahmen für einzelne länder
innerhalb der währungsunion
vorzubereiten auch hier gilt die
bundesregierung herr bundeskanzler ist
im rahmen des mandats der europäischen
zentralbank gebunden an die entscheidung
des euro der des deutschen
bundesverfassungsgerichtes vom 5 mai
2020 will das hier noch einmal in
erinnerung rufen vor allem sind sie
gebunden an die strikte an die strikte
regeln dass anleihen für die europäische
zentralbank nur quartal nach den
jeweiligen kapitalschlüssel der
nationalen zentralbanken gekauft werden
das hört sich jetzt sehr technisch an in
wahrheit meine damen und herren ist dies
eine ganz wesentliche politische frage
der zukünftigen stabilität der
europäischen währungsunion wenn die
europäische zentralbank ihren auftrag
weiter erfüllen für geldwertstabilität
zu sorgen und nur für geldwertstabilität
ein anderes mandat hat die europäische
zentralbank nicht
und es
ist schon das ist schon weiter
aufschlussreich dass sie in diesen tagen
mit dieser regierungserklärung heute
morgen den stabilitäts und wachstumspakt
der europäischen union mit keinem wort
erwähnen obwohl er in diesen tagen
gerade 25 jahre alt wird und man
eigentlich doch die gelegenheit hätte
nutzen können mal zu sagen die
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland hält ohne wenn und aber an
den zielen des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspakt der europäischen
währungsunion fest das hätten wir
eigentlich gerade vor dem hintergrund
der gegenwärtigen verschuldung und
zinsentwicklung von ihm erwartet der
bundeskanzler
die menschen die menschen machen sich
nicht nur sorge um den krieg in der
ukraine und die mögliche ausweitung
sondern auch um die inflation und die
geldentwertung und um die
zinsentwicklung je höher die schulden um
so höher ist die inflation auch hierzu
hätte es ein wort durchaus verdient
gesagt zu werden etwas zu den schulden
und zudem zinsen in der europäischen
währungsunion der bundeskanzler sie
haben diese gelegenheit leider nicht
genutzt fiel deswegen für uns sagen wenn
sie sich an irgendeiner stelle auf den
weg machen eine transfer-union und eine
schuldenunion in der europäischen
währungsunion zu ermöglichen dann werden
sie auf den erbitterten widerstand
unserer bundestagsfraktion dabei stoßen
und wir werden alles geben und genau das
um genau das
das nämlich ausschließen c7 gefühl dass
sie mit abschlüssen zum g 7 lassen sie
mich also den zwischen herrschten halte
ich im protokoll gerne fest dass das von
vorgestern ist stabilität und
währungsstabilität von vorgestern diesen
zwischen rauswurf aus der spd meine
damen und herren den märken worden und
daraufhin dabei gelegenheit gern das
werden die menschen in deutschland die
chance größer tankverhalten aussprechen
klasse nicht abschließend einen satz
unser zwei sätze zum g7-gipfel ich es
ist eine sehr kluge entscheidung herr
bundeskanzler
einige länder hier als gäste einzuladen
sie haben südafrika senegal indonesien
indien in argentinien genannt also über
südafrika kann man streiten ob da nicht
vielleicht australien sinnvoller gewesen
wäre statt südafrika aber immerhin sie
haben indien eingeladen das ist eine
strategisch sehr kluge entscheidung dass
sie ein land das einst zu den größten
der welt zählt mit einladen die auch
über die zukünftige politische ordnung
der welt zu diskutieren
wir hätten ihnen gerne noch ein kleines
gastgeber geschenk mit in ihr
reisegepäck gegeben wir hätten nämlich
spätestens heute wir in spätestens heute
das handelsabkommen mit kanada
verabschieden können dann wäre diese
initiative umso glaubwürdiger gewesen
dass sie diese länder einladen
zumindest alle wissen
funktionierende koalition der bundestag
hat heute morgen und plätze das aus des
deutschen bundestages zum fünften mal
hintereinander die ratifikation dieses
abkommens ihrem deutschen bundestag
abgelehnt sagen sie wenn sie mit diesen
ländern reden wollen und wir müssen mit
diesen ländern reden warum sind sie denn
dann nicht in der lage ihrer koalition
mal zu sagen wir verabschieden vor einem
solchen großen gipfel wo die kanadier
dabei sind dieses freihandelsabkommen
mit
das wäre wirklich glaubwürdig gewesen
dann hätten die pächter hat auch aus der
mitte des deutschen bundestages wollen
sie haben es nicht hinbekommen zu
schaffen ist offensichtlich nicht auch
ihre koalition da zur vernunft zu
bringen wir wünschen ihnen und der
bundesregierung trotzdem viel erfolg bei
diesen wichtigen gipfeln die jetzt
bevorstehen wir bleiben skeptisch und
das werden sie uns nachsehen wenn ich
das sage ob sie in zwei wochen mit den
ergebnissen nach berlin wirklich
zurückkehren die europa- und die auch
unser land nun in dieser schwierigen
situation jetzt zu bringen brauchen
herzlichen dank
ja sobald also rede und gegenrede live
aus dem bundestag das war eine ganze
menge wir können das unmögliche alles
zusammenfassen aber ich versuche mal ein
paar wichtige punkte noch einmal
aufzugreifen zunächst der bundeskanzler
er hat noch mal darüber gesprochen dass
die bundeswehr wirksam ausgestattet
werde in der nächsten zeit teilweise
auch schon ist man habe zusätzliche
kräfte in östliche nato grenzgebiete
verlegt werden die präsenz weiter
ausbauen so scholz und werden auch jeden
teil des bündnisgebietes verteidigen das
hat er nochmal wiederholt eine
strategische partnerschaft mit russland
auf absehbare zeit unvorstellbar dennoch
soll an der nato russland grund akte
festgehalten werden denn sie sei dem
geiste nach immer noch richtig schweden
und finnland sollen ihnen die nato auch
dafür werde er sich einsetzen
europa stehe geschlossen an der seite
der ukraine auch dafür werde er sich
einsetzen das ist also auf dem eu-gipfel
dann auch ein klares jahr zum
kandidatenstatus der ukraine kommt
sowohl der ukraine als auch moldau
georgien wurde später dann auch noch
erwähnt man müsse allerdings auch die eu
reformieren um sie aufnahmefähig zu
machen auch die länder des westbalkans
müssten zügig aufgenommen werden und
hunger und armut das ist jetzt ein
weltweites phänomen das müsse auch in
den griff bekommen werden auch da
appelliert er daran dass auf dem
g7-gipfel g7-treffen g7-gipfel jetzt in
der nächsten in den nächsten tagen dort
fortschritte erzielt werden aus der
zeitenwende ergeben sich einen
handlungsauftrag für deutschland man
trage große verantwortung und der wolle
man auch gerecht werden so der
bundeskanzler nun zum oppositionschef
friedrich merz er sagt der besuch in
kiew war richtig trotzdem das problem
bleibt nun mal dass der krieg mehr und
mehr zu einem völkermord werde er
begrüßte die veröffentlichung der
lieferung der waffenlieferung früher
wäre allerdings besser gewesen putin
muss in der ukraine gestoppt werden so
sein plädoyer damit er da auch nicht auf
andere gedanken kommt noch
weiterzumachen zweifel ob es der kanzler
ernst meine mit seinen ankündigungen
würden sich auch aus verschiedenen
äußerungen sowohl des kanzlers als auch
vor allem aus seiner partei ergeben und
last but not least der stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt der eu dürfe nicht
gefährdet werden eine transfer und
schuldenunion das ist bekannt aus der in
union lehne man nachdrücklich ab also
dass in der gebotenen kürze vielleicht
nochmal die wesentlichen aussagen dieser
beiden reden und darüber sprechen wir
jetzt noch ein weilchen mit unserem
kollegen vor ort mit daniel pontzen er
ist uns zugeschaltet aus berlin aus dem
hauptstadtstudio ja daniel also es war
eine ganze menge stoff dabei vielleicht
mal da in aller erster eindruck die
regierungserklärung des kanzlers wie war
sie aus deiner sicht einzuschätzen war
es überraschend war es angriffslustig
wie hast du es erlebt
ich würde sagen weder besonders
überraschend noch besonders
angriffslustig es war im grunde ja doch
so ziemlich im rahmen dessen was zu
erwarten war es war noch einmal eine
ausgeruhte auflistung all jene punkte
die
ja im vorfeld schon thema gewesen waren
was sie gerade alle nochmal referiert
wirklich große überraschung war
überhaupt nicht dabei aus meiner sicht
klar da eine einige dinge noch einmal
sehr deutlich ausbuchstabiert zum
beispiel eben dass es mit blick auf den
nato-gipfel eben nicht mehr diese
partnerschaft mit dass nicht mehr das
ziel geben könne eine partnerschaft mit
russland wie sie auch im strategischen
konzept von 210 vorgesehen war
anzustreben auf absehbare zeit das
klingt allerdings nach der sogenannten
zeitenwende ja fast schon wie eine
selbstverständlichkeit man fragt sich er
man fühlt sich zurückversetzt
in eine zeit das wo man sich das noch
vorstellen konnte und ansonsten würde
ich sagen war auch friedrich merz im
verhältnis im vergleich zu dem was man
in vergangenen reden im bundestag als
reaktion auch auf den bundeskanzler auf
die spd gehört hat vergleichsweise
zahm oder zumindest nicht so
angriffslustig wie wegen schon erlebt
haben allerdings hat er natürlich auch
schon noch mal sehr deutlich
hervorgehoben und diese formulierung
fand ich da
bezeichneten dass unsere wie er sagt
unsere schutzverantwortung
für die ukraine betont werden müsse um
einen völkermord dort abzuwenden für den
es immer mehr anzeichen gebe und er hat
ja noch mal zum abschluss seiner rede
betont dass man sehr genau darauf
schauen werde mit welchen ergebnissen
der bundeskanzler von den drei gipfeln
jetzt zurückkommen wird insofern würde
ich sagen sind diese themen jetzt im
rahmen dessen was zu erwarten war
besprochen worden und sozusagen und holt
wenn man so will im bundestag vielleicht
nochmal 2 kommentare unserer userinnen
und user was das thema waffenlieferungen
an georgien graudus schreibt uns über
youtube die ukraine braucht noch mehr
schwere waffen bitte nicht quatschen
sondern liefern contra waffenlieferungen
wiederum über facebook amazon bauer
sofortiger stopp jeglicher
waffenlieferungen welche den krieg nur
verlängern würden nun ja also die
waffenlieferung glas ist auch gerade
angesprochen da nicht die sind nun
veröffentlicht wie würdest du diesen
schritt jetzt bewerten wie wurde das
heute diskutiert im bundestag war das
strategisch sozusagen wichtig dass die
regierung das jetzt vor dieser debatte
gemacht hat
das war zumindest
insoweit erfolgreich aus der sicht des
bundeskanzlers als er diese geforderte
transparenz ja nun eingelöst hat das hat
friedrich merz ja auch in seiner rede
anerkannt gesagt er hätte sich das
durchaus schon früher vorstellen können
aber immerhin ist man jetzt nun auf
diese strategie umgeschwenkt hier wie
eingangs schon dargelegt sehr
gegenteilig ist zudem was man vorher
praktiziert hat nämlich höchste
geheimhaltung
trotzdem wird uns das thema erhalten
bleiben wir hatten eingangs ja auch
schon mal über die einlassung der
bundesverteidigungsministerium heute im
bundestag vor der regierungserklärung
des bundeskanzlers gesprochen und sie
hat ja noch mal auf die unterscheidung
hingewiesen von abgaben aus der
bundeswehr und lieferungen aus der
industrie und hier bleibt es natürlich
bei einem gewissen widerspruch denn die
verteidigungsministerin hat in den
letzten wochen immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass die bestände der
bundeswehr endlich das sie begrenzt sind
man deswegen aus diesen beständen eben
auch nur begrenzt dinge abgeben kann
gleichzeitig hat sie betont dass
schnelle hilfe nötig sei um so mehr
fragt man
dreht der industrie
schützenpanzer zum beispiel dass die
nicht ab dass hierüber keine
entscheidung im bundessicherheitsrat
getroffen wird die industrie ist hier
abgabe bereit die ukraine will dieses
gerät unbedingt haben und wenn die
schnelligkeit wie frau lambrecht betont
hat sich das ziel wäre dann müsste er
zumindest jetzt seine entscheidung
eigentlich getroffen werden also die ein
oder andere frage frage bleibt da
durchaus noch offen das waren die
einschätzungen von unserem kollegen
daniel johnston aus dem hauptstadtstudio
in berlin ganz herzlichen dank daniel
und wir sprechen weiter mit katrin
eigendorf sie ist uns zugeschaltet aus
der ukraine genauer
holen muss ich manchmal an letztens habe
ich allerdings einen ton genau den
himmel runter das ist die viertgrößte
stadt des landes mit rund einer
millionen einwohnern und sie liegt etwa
400 kilometer südöstlich der hauptstadt
kiew
kathrin ich grüße dich zunächst mal
welche erwartungen verbinden sich denn
in der ukraine mit der regierung das
erklärung des bundeskanzlers wären sie
gerade gehört wir haben auch erwähnt auf
allen jetzt anstehenden gipfeln wird es
um das thema gehen krieg in der ukraine
also was ist die erwartungshaltung an
deutschland
also die erwartungshaltung an
deutschland ist sehr sehr hoch wie in
der ukraine und was man liest von
kommentatoren sind sich eigentlich alle
einig dass die nächsten tage sehr sehr
entscheidend für die ukraine ihre
kriegsführung aber auch ihre zukunft
sein wird und da erwartet man von
deutschland das ja eine führende rolle
sowohl in der eu als auch bei g 7 als
auch in der nato spielt dass es da
entsprechend position bezieht und für
die ukraine eintritt ich habe mir mal
während der regierungserklärung auf
social media so die kommentare mal so
überflogen dies zu der rede gab da gab
es schon einiges was an schnellen
reaktionen zu entdecken war fand ich
auch selber ganz interessant dass das so
hoch hoch an steht hier in der ukraine
das war eigentlich von den kommentaren
fast alles sehr positiv denke mal
natürlich auch vor dem hintergrund dass
die ukraine jetzt sieht deutschland
redet nicht nur sondern handelt also
einfach diese positive nachricht dass
deutschland jetzt wirklich endlich
waffen liefert das ist hier gestern ja
sehr positiv aufgenommen worden ich
denke vor dem hintergrund kann man auch
diese positiven kommentare sehen also
man verbindet kurz um sehr sehr viel
einerseits mit diesen gipfelmarathons
aber zweitens auch mit der rolle die
deutschland einnehmen wird dafür
sprecher für die ukraine zu sein wie
groß das misstrauen im prinzip noch vor
ein paar tagen war habe ich einen witz
entnommen da hat man hat einen
kommentator geschrieben ja als
als makro und scholz in kiew waren
hätten wir uns auch vorstellen können
vielleicht sind sie hier um uns zu
überreden in neue verhandlungen mit
russland einzutreten das ist ja noch mal
gut gegangen es ist zwar ein scherz aber
das misstrauen war hier lange sehr groß
bei der ukraine ist es wirklich so dass
frankreich und deutschland vor allem an
erster stelle
wirklich für die interessen der ukraine
einstehen positionen beziehen auch gegen
russland und insofern wird diese
regierungserklärungen natürlich auch in
der abgrenzung die stolze möglichen
russland vorgenommen hat als sehr
positiv bewertet
ja also das ist das eine was scholz
zugesagt hat eben das politische gewicht
sozusagen in die waagschale zu werfen um
dafür zu werben dass der beitritt status
eben dann auch kommt was die eu an geht
jetzt auf dem gipfel auf der anderen
seite natürlich braucht es immer noch
das schwere gerät die waffen wie ist da
momentan sozusagen die haltung in der
ukraine was wird am dringendsten jetzt
von von deutschland was dieses feld
angeht gefordert
also die ukraine betont ja seit anfang
des krieges immer wieder wir brauchen
schwere waffen wir müssen vor allem der
artillerie überlegenheit russlands etwas
entgegen setzen wir sind ja hier nur 150
kilometer von der front entfernt und wir
waren heute hier in einem
militärkrankenhaus und da hatte ich
gelegenheit auch mit soldaten zu
sprechen die mir geschildert haben also
verwundete soldaten die mir geschildert
haben wie die situation an der front ist
und dass sie einfach gar nicht genug
wirklich moderne waffen haben dass das
sehr sehr entscheidend ist und sie haben
gesagt dann nochmal das eigentlich dass
der wirkliche traum wäre dass die nato
dafür sorgt dass der luftraum über der
ukraine geschlossen wird aber das ist
natürlich eine traumvorstellung also man
hat sich mittlerweile davon
verabschiedet von dieser
von dieser annahme dass das möglich ist
und drängt jetzt darauf wirklich schwere
waffen hier so schnell wie möglich ins
land zu bringen auch entsprechende
munition dazu und die ausbildung der
soldaten ist natürlich auch wichtig weil
die zeit drängt doch hier sehr wenn man
sich anguckt wie hier der kriegsverlauf
gerade im osten der ukraine also im don
was ist es ist schon so dass die russen
jetzt im moment dabei sind es droht hier
dass die ukrainischen streitkräfte
eingezahlt werden und sie haben dem
einfach nichts wirklich starkes
entgegenzusetzen ja über die
militärischen sozusagen gegebenheiten
und feinheiten wenn wir gleich noch mit
egon ramms sprechen aber weil du auch
angesprochen hast dass du eben auch im
austausch ist natürlich mit den menschen
vor ort die vielen verluste welche
auswirkungen haben diese auf die
mentalität der leute macht sich langsam
doch so etwas wie kriegsmüdigkeit breit
oder gar verzweiflung wie ist das
ich kann natürlich keine repräsentativen
umfragen hier durchführen das sind immer
auch nur eindrücke die ich habe und die
eindrücke die ich hier gewonnen habe ist
mir ist bisher niemand begegnet der was
du sagst kriegsmüde ist oder diesen
krieg in irgendeiner form in zweifel
zieht natürlich sehen die leute
mittlerweile dass dieser krieg
möglicherweise noch sehr lange dauern
kann dass sich das nicht so schnell
entscheiden wird und dass die opfer die
hier zu bringen sind vermutlich wie viel
größer sein könnten als dass man das am
anfang angenommen hat ich meine in den
krankenhäusern sieht man ja wie die
soldaten hier ankommen man sieht die
vielen verletzten zivilisten die vielen
toten die zerstörten städte das lastet
natürlich sehr oft der ukraine aber alle
haben mir übereinstimmend gesagt ob das
ärzte sind ob das soldaten sind ob das
normale bürger sind ob das journalisten
sind wir werden diesen krieg bis zum
ende führen
es ist für uns alternativlos weil wir
werden nicht zulassen dass russland
unser land besetzt also das ist ganz
klar common sense in der ukraine und
damit auch stützt würde ich sagen die
mehrheit der bevölkerung auch den kurs
von präsident sie lenski es gibt hier
auch so einem seil sondern auch eine art
scherz wenn es um die waffenlieferungen
gibt geht da sagen die ukraine ok selbst
wenn ihr uns nicht waffen liefert und
damit wollen sie im prinzip jegliche
diskussionen in der hinsicht beenden
notfalls verteidigen wir uns halt mit
schaufeln aber wir werden unser land
verteidigen also es wird noch gescherzt
aber das sind natürlich verzweifelte
auch scherze in gewisser hinsicht das
waren die schilderungen von katrin
eigendorf aus der ukraine genauer gesagt
aus in je pro ganz ganz herzlichen dank
für diese eindrücke und bis zum nächsten
mal danke schön
so und wir machen weiter mit
mit einem echten general zumindest einem
a d nato general egon ramms er ist uns
zugeschaltet ich grüße sie herr am
guten teuer werbung herms sie haben die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
verfolgt da ging es ja unter anderem
auch um ja die militärischen aspekte der
hilfe die deutschland leistet hat sie da
irgend etwas überrascht erfreut da oder
wie würden sie momentan die
hilfeleistungen aus deutschland bewerten
wir können uns gleich auch noch einmal
gemeinsam die veröffentlichte liste
anschauen
also mich hat eigentlich soll der
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
nicht allzuviel überrascht denn es ist
im prinzip eine zusammenfassung der
ereignisse gewesen die seitdem dort der
rede zur zeitenwende am 27.2
stattgefunden haben natürlich auch mit
veränderungen dabei wir wissen alle wie
lange die bundesregierung gebraucht hat
um zu entscheiden schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern gestern sind die
panzerhaubitzen angekommen dass es eine
verstärkung für die ukrainische ag die
die ukrainische artillerie dazu
befähigen wird die russische artillerie
zu bekämpfen und die überlegenheit der
russen des ausgesprochen groß
das ist wichtig für die ukraine genauso
wie das thema schwere waffen wie immer
sagen ich würde lieber von panzern und
schützenpanzern
mannschaftstransportwagen gepanzerten
transportwagen reden und das etwas
besser zu spezifizieren und vielleicht
auch das durcheinander im wissen zu
werden die ukraine braucht diese systeme
einfach um gegen die russen weiterhin
entsprechend kämpfen zu können und sie
braucht sie vor allen dingen wenn sie
die absicht hat geländegewinne zu
erzielen und damit die russen in
wichtigen bereichen
zurück zu drücken ich bin davon
überzeugt wenn solche waffen in größerer
zahl bereits da gewesen wären sähe die
lage in lustig und es wäre dort
vielleicht etwas anders aus als heute
aussieht sie sich vielleicht schon
anders als ja wir können wie gesagt
gerne noch mal gemeinsam schauen auf
unserer seite zdf heute.de haben wir
nochmal zusammengefasst welche waffen
deutschland bereits geliefert hat bzw
welche noch geliefert werden sollen da
ist eben auch von den schweren waffen
systemen die sie gerade angesprochen
haben die rede also 30 flac panzer des
typs gp sieben panzer witzen die sind
inzwischen angekommen drei mehrfach
raketenwerfer maß mit munition et cetera
das alles ist wie gesagt auf dieser
seite nachzulesen das ist teilweise
schon da teilweise aber noch in planung
auch weitere 54 gepanzerte
truppentransporter auch die hatten sie
gerade schon angesprochen
das soll noch kommen und dann ist aber
auch auf dieser auflistung dabei das
bereits 25 punkte
ein 38 38 punkte manchmal ein bisschen
schwierig hier den überblick zu behalten
38 punkte wurden aufgeführt die bereits
geliefert sind 16 millionen schusswaffen
munition das sind ja auch unvorstellbare
mengen die jedenfalls mehr als laie groß
vorkommen wie würden sie wenn sie jetzt
noch einmal darauf schauen und sich eben
auch noch mal vor augen führen was
bereits geliefert wurde und was noch
aussteht das bewerten und wie schnell
vor allem muss jetzt das gerät kommen
lassen sich mit der letzten frage
anfangen also es besteht in der ukraine
mit blick auf den kampf gegen die
russischen kräfte ein ungeheurer
zeitdruck und jeder quadratmeter boden
der unter ukraine verloren geht muss
nach den ich sag mal leitlinien des
präsidenten irgendwann wieder zurück
erobert werden und zurück erobern ist
möglicherweise schwieriger als
erfolgreich verteidigen das heißt wir
haben einen die menschen zeitpunkt
dahinter und alle länder die die ukraine
unterstützen auch die bundesrichter
stand sollten sich darum bemühen dieses
material so schnell wie möglich an die
ukraine zu liefern um die ukrainische
streitkräfte für einen erfolgreichen
kampf zu befähigen und diesen
erfolgreichen kampf brauchen wir denn
nach meiner auffassung ist wladimir
putin und russland zur zeit dabei ich
formuliere das mit meinen worten ein
volk zu vernichten dafür sprechen auch
die deputation durchgeführt hat die
trennung von familie und kindern
adoption von kindern deren eltern
möglicherweise noch leben und
dergleichen dinge mehr das heißt er will
die ukraine als einen teil russlands
komplett besetzen und er möchte im
prinzip das ukrainische volk auf diese
art und weise vernichten und das ist
eine sache die wir auch gerade wir
deutschen mit unserer geschichte in
keinem fall zu lassen sollten von daher
besteht hoher zeitdruck und wir sollten
alles tun die waffen so schnell wie
möglich dorthin zu bekommen
katerina art der andere teil der andere
teil der frage
der andere teil der frage ich möchte
jetzt nicht auf diese 38 positionen der
gelieferten artikel eingehen weil es
dann vom verbandpäckchen bis zur
verpflegung hätte ich bei einer gesagt
ziemlich verzetteln würden sondern
richtig ist dass diese sachen geliefert
worden sind dass die ukraine sie braucht
dass die ukraine sie hat und lieferungen
dieser art so sehe ich das im augenblick
werden auch weitergehen weil die ukraine
einen bestimmten rückhalt brauchen ein
bestimmtes backup braucht um die
gefechte weiter führen zu können und die
ukraine ist praktisch selbst nicht mehr
in der lage krieg später in dieser art
zu produzieren
von daher ist sie zu 100 prozent auf die
hilfe von außerhalb angewiesen und da
sollte deutschland sich in jedem fall
bemühen auch eine wichtige rolle zu
spielen
katharina art fragt uns über youtube wie
lang kann dieser krieg noch dauern das
ist natürlich eine frage die schwer zu
beantworten sein dürfte aber wie würden
sie es jetzt anhand der momentanen
entwicklung vielleicht einschätzen
also ich gehe davon aus dass wir am ende
des krieges in diesem jahr nicht mehr
erleben werden das ist meine hoch
richtung die kann sogar falschen
möglicherweise geht es auch länger auch
das hängt davon ab wann die ukraine mehr
waffen bekommt und die waffen kriegt um
die russischen streitkräfte entsprechend
bekämpfen zu können und solange das
nicht möglich ist oder sagen der zustand
der ukrainischen streitkräfte so ist wir
zurzeit ist und wo vor allen dingen die
große kampfes leistung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte von der kampfmoral abhängig
ist wird es keine wende geben höchstens
band lokalen gefechten in saison zum
beispiel wo die ukrainische soldaten
dann vielleicht ein paar
quadratkilometer boden zurückgewinnen
werden die übrigens taktisch nicht
unwichtig sind weil es wichtig wäre die
russen hinter diesem fluss zurück zu
werfen also mindestens ein halbes jahr
oder länger und es hängt ab von der
unterstützung die wir liefern das ist
für mich die gelegenheit nutzen auf die
eine bemerkung einzugehen jede
gelieferte waffen verlängert den krieg
die sie vorhin zitieren haben ja ich
finde diese bemerkung finde ich
menschenunwürdig und zwar aus folgendem
grund jemand der da schreibt und damit
im prinzip putin seinen siegen gibt die
ukraine zu erobern ist
mit beteiligt an der verpflichtung des
ukrainischen volkes und das sind
schreckliche idee für mich
ich würde gerne mit ihnen noch einmal
auf einen spezifischen punkt sozusagen
in der ukraine zu sprechen kommt je yoo
donetzk schwer auszusprechen seit wochen
ist der ort in den schlagzeilen weil es
sich dort eben eine tapfer muss man
sagen kämpfende ukrainische minderheit
noch hält befürchtet wird aber eben seit
wochen die 1 klasse solo einkesselung
dieser truppen durch russland wir haben
da auch eine karte verbreitet vielleicht
gucken wir da gerade noch mal drauf und
dann können wir das vielleicht auch an
der stelle noch mal etwas genauer zeigen
so wurde es mir jedenfalls gesagt wenn
wir die karte nicht haben ist es nicht
weiter tragisch dann frage ich sie so
wie würden sie die situation was diesen
ort angeht beschreiben
wir haben uns in dieser sendung wenn ich
das richtig erinnere vor etwa 14 tagen
über dieses thema schon mal unterhalten
und ich habe damals die empfehlung
gegeben dass es vielleicht besser wäre
mit einer front begradigung von der
ukrainischen seite her die truppen aus
diesem teil herauszunehmen und auf diese
art und weise
menschenleben zu sparen die man
möglicherweise hinter für den weiteren
krieg noch brauchen wird und auf diese
art und weise b auch die gefahr einer
einkesselung und diese dinge einfach
zu minimieren darf ich da keine
zwischenfragen rainer haben zur
verteidigung so was weiß jetzt nicht
jeder was ist damit gemeint
ok also es geht darum dass in diesem ich
nenne es mal einen sack der sich dort
gebildet hat mit den russischen
streitkräften
die gefahr besteht dass diese beiden
städte lösung chance und zwar
grundsätzlich eingeschlossen werden und
damit dann ukrainische soldaten zu
kriegsgefangenen werden oder von den
russen gar getötet werden
und das könnte man möglicherweise mit
einem oder hätte man vorher mit einem
taktischen rückzug vermeiden können ob
dieser taktischen rückzug doch
funktioniert dafür fehlen mir im
augenblick die details verstehen wie
schätzen sie denn insgesamt die
situation ein gerade wenn wir jetzt mal
auch über das material sprechen sie
hatten gerade schon auch die moral
angesprochen unsere kollegen vor ort
katrin eigendorf konnte uns jedenfalls
keine gegenteiligen eindrücke schildern
also die sei offenbar noch intakt aber
wenn wir jetzt mal auf das material
schauen da werden zahlen gemeldet von
zehnfache überlegenheit teilweise 15 20
facher überlegenheit wie viele reserven
hat russland noch was was glauben sie
also ich denke dass die reserven
russlands mittlerweile auch angegriffen
worden sind und von daher sich auch
einschränken dazu kommt eine
interessante aussage die gestern gemacht
worden ist in den russischen kanälen
nämlich die aussage dass man kräfte
bereithalten wird im bereich litauen der
drei baltischen staaten damit man dort
nicht in einem risiko rein läuft das was
dort völlig überflüssiger weise
möglicherweise an kräften von von diesen
drei baltischen staaten russischen
kräften gebunden wird führt dazu dass
diese kräfte auf dem gefechtsfeld in der
ukraine nicht auftauchen können von
daher hat das in interessanten
nebeneffekt obwohl diese blockade
insbesondere von metallwaren und
dergleichen mehr eigentlich keine
kriegshandlungen ist so wichtig die
ausführung der sanktionen die durch die
europäische union beschlossen worden
sind apropos un-sanktionen ich es
vielleicht noch mal die ein oder andere
user meinung vor ich glaube nicht
schreibt uns nm über youtube dass
russland wegen der sanktionen aufhören
wird auch wenn die sanktionen ab herbst
stärker wirken hauptziel von putin ist
es die sowjetunion wieder herzustellen
gerlinde boards und mainz aber ob eine
ausweitung des konflikts noch zu finden
ist möchte ich doch mehr als bezweifeln
also offenbar auch auf andere staaten es
sollte keine diplomatische lösung geben
auch wenn man das kaum begreifen kann
vielleicht machen sie auch eine
diplomatische lösung so sehe ich das
kommen wir noch mal auf die aktuelle
klar
sie dürfen auch gerne kommentieren ja
also ich möchte noch mal den hinweis
geben wirklich den nachdrücklichen
hinweis geben dass es nicht um die frage
geht
wo wir den russen entgegenkommen können
oder dergleichen sondern nicht verweise
auf das was für durch märz als
oppositionsführer gesagt hat dort wo wir
westlichen staaten dazu zählen alle also
auch die modus zurück deutschland
signale senden dass wir uns mit den
russen an einen verhandlungstisch setzen
wollen zeigen wir aus putins perspektive
schwäche und er wird bereit sein diese
schwäche in jeder form aus nutzen dh die
geschlossenheit von unserer seite und
das fortsetzen der unterstützung in der
ukraine ist letztendlich ein starkes
signal auch an claudia putin und ich
möchte ihren zuschauer vielleicht ein
bisschen die sorge nehmen ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass putin jetzt will litauen
oder an anderer stelle einen krieg gegen
die nato vom zaun brechen wird denn ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher dass er weiß
dass er diesen krieg nicht gewinnen kann
von daher wäre das dann auch ein
erheblicher nachteil für russland selber
den er so vermute ich dass trotz
manchmal fehlen rationales nicht bereit
ist hinzunehmen hier haben wir noch eine
zuschrift die militärisches wissen
offenbar voraussetzt sanktionen richten
in deutschland deutlich mehr schaden an
und russland hat den längeren atem
außerdem außerdem geht von kaliningrad
eine reale gefahr aus klammer auf
iskander raketen mit atomsprengköpfen
was würden sie diese zuschrift entgegnen
also kaliningrad kaliningrad hat immer
schon truppen stationiert gehabt hat
immer schon teile der baltischen flotte
der russlands und vorher auch der
sowjetunion gehabt und kaliningrad war
immer ein ich sag das mal militär
verschiebe platz für die russische oder
die sowjetische seite wir leben mit
diesem zustand im prinzip seit 1946 also
auch nachdem die nato 49 gegründet wurde
ist haben wir diesen zustand
weitergetragen und ich bin so ehrlich zu
sagen dass ich mir ein paar mal die
frage gestellt habe warum lassen hier
eine situation wie diese zu ohne
überhaupt über kaliningrad und diese
situation nachzudenken wenn putin davon
ausgehen kann dass alles was er
russisches als russisches territorium
bezeichnet ein sanktuarium ist muss er
sich über russland keine sorgen machen
dann wird es dort diesen krieg egal wie
der ausgeht in jedem fall entsprechend
überleben
ich sehe die gefahr eines angriffes auf
die nato sehe ich nicht weil die nato
weiterhin und das wird in der nächsten
woche auch beim gipfel tun sehr deutlich
machen wird dass die nato ihr
territorium verteidigt keinen
angriffskrieg gegen russland
beabsichtigt von daher gibt es keinen
grund es sei denn putin will den auf
teufel komm raus herbeireden um seine
eigene handlung zu rechtfertigen und das
macht er und das machen seine männer
beispielsweise auch die regelmäßig mit
den militärischen erfolgen im fernsehen
auftreten ausgesprochen geschickt
wir müssen lernen dass russland eine
harte verhandlungstaktik betreibt und
wir müssen eine silbe harten
verhandlungstaktik seinem verhalten den
gegensätzen sonst kommen wir nie an
einen echten verhandlungstisch oder
tatsächlich über die zukunft der ukraine
nach den vorgaben der ukraine verhandelt
werden kann aber die äußerungen was die
nato auch die bereitschaft angeht der
nato-staaten jeden zentimeter sozusagen
des territoriums zu verteidigen die
halten sie für glaubhaft weil hier
schreibt uns papa klaus über youtube
körper klaus klepper strauß heißt sowohl
die nato oder er ist ein alibi bündnis
bei einem angriff russlands wird niemand
litauen helfen außer mit
waffenlieferungen wie sehen sie das
also ich das sehe ich anders die
bekenntnisse aller nato staaten
sicherlich auch in gewisser form
abgestuft aber ich verweise jetzt auf
die regierungserklärung unseres kanzlers
die agrana abgegeben hat das bekenntnis
aller nato staaten nato territorium zu
verteidigen steht und auf grund der des
verhaltens von wladimir putin in den
letzten 20 jahren was wir bereits oder
vielleicht einige male falsch beurteilt
haben haben wir eine situation wo so
glaube ich auch im westen der zorn auf
das was russland beziehungsweise
wladimir putin betreibt sehr groß ist
von daher glaube ich nicht wirklich
nicht bin ich davon überzeugt dass
beispielsweise mit blick auf litauen die
deutsche battlegroup dort abgezogen
würde ganz im gegenteil der kanzlerin
einer seiner vorangehenden reden noch
mal deutlich gemacht dass er die absicht
hat beim nato-gipfel vorzuschlagen dass
diese kräfte die sich in den baltischen
staaten befinden verstärkt werden sollen
das war schon mal eine idee im jahr 2016
die damals leider verworfen worden ist
aber diese idee kommt jetzt wieder das
zeigt dass die oder die damals die lage
2016 also nach der annexion der krim
beurteilt haben die lage richtig
beurteilt haben und man hätte manche
dinge voraussehen können sich davor
darauf einstellen können
letzte frage herr rams von mir sie
hatten für ihn angesprochen dass der
krieg wohl noch einige zeit dauern werde
was glauben sie welche kampftaktik der
ukraine werden wir da in den nächsten
wochen und monaten erleben vor allem
wenn es bei dieser übermacht der russen
bleiben sollte die materiell offenbar
momentan vorhanden es wird es dazu sei
eine art guerillakrieg kommen der
offenbar dann sehr blutig werden wird
der ist ja ohnehin schon blutig dieser
krieg aber könnte es dann nochmal eine
weitere dimension geben mit häuserkampf
und allem
also ich möchte noch mal einen punkt
deutlich unterstreichen das was zurzeit
in der ukraine passiert dass der
vormarsch der russischen streitkräfte
jeweils durch eine artilleriefeuer weise
unterstützt wird die ganze ortschaften
zerstört die keine rücksicht auf die
zivilbevölkerung nimmt ist ein
untragbarer unhaltbarer zustand auch mit
blick auf die liste der kriegsverbrechen
von russischer seite her die immer
länger wird
die frage ob man einen partizan oder
guerilla krieg führen wird hängt zum
teil ab vom gelände das gelände muss
sich für eine solche formen des kampfes
eignen die ukrainischen kräfte müssten
in der lage sein russische streitkräfte
schnell anzugreifen zu schlagen und dann
schnell wieder zu verschwinden bevor sie
beispielsweise von einer neuen
russischen artillerie feuerwalze erfasst
werden das ist eine möglichkeit die aber
wie gesagt die länder abhängig ist und
die ich im augenblick so noch nicht sehe
obwohl sie mich das richtig im kopf habe
westlich von person und einem abschnitt
der südlich des flusses nicht bereits
praktiziert wird der nato general egon
ramms war das für uns mit seinen
einschätzungen zur vor allem
militärischen situation in der ukraine
ganz herzlichen dank herr amt für das
gespräch
ja da hat sich ja auf wiedersehen bis
zum nächsten mal und das gleiche gilt
natürlich auch für euch wir danken ganz
herzlich für die aufmerksamkeit das war
unser live stream anlässlich der
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
es steht ein gipfel marathon bevor in
oder bei den gipfeln wird es
hauptsächlich eben auch um die situation
in der ukraine gehen und deswegen haben
wir darüber heute ausführlicher
gesprochen dankeschön für euer interesse
und fürs mitmachen bis zum nächsten mal
auf wiedersehen zschau